our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us there
are more than 37 thousand homeless
veterans in the United States this
morning we introduce you to the veterans
community project a missouri nonprofit
working to change that Dean Reynolds
toured their village of 49 tiny homes
that provides everything from furniture
to fully stocked refrigerators to help
vets get back on their feet I was there
all the way up until I was wounded far
from the foreign battlefields that once
gave his life a purpose former Army
sniper Kyle Prell Berg has come home
what does it mean to you to be here oh
it's huge it's it's it's been enormous
ly helpful to be around more veterans as
is the big is the big selling point to
me Prell burg now resides in one of 49
so-called tiny homes 240 to 360 square
feet built by the veterans community
project here in Kansas City specifically
for homeless warriors men and women for
whom life away from the military has
been hard it got to the point that I
didn't really care so much about myself
you know stopped taking care of myself
nobody's relying on me and you know it
became what's the point
veterans have twice the risk of becoming
chronically homeless as other Americans
this neighborhood where Purple Hearts
mixed with post-traumatic stress is
designed to get warriors off the streets
back on their feet and looking ahead
when I came home from the military we
didn't order transition - you know I
transition out of the barracks lifestyle
and to living with my parents right
Brandon Mixon is a former army
helicopter crew chief and a co-founder
of this project which not only provides
shelter but all kinds of services for
vets mental health job training personal
finances and more for free
do you have success stories oh
absolutely I'm not trying to sound
cliche but every veteran that walks
through our door is a success story and
that's just because we're able to remind
them hey dude you're not alone if you're
battling with something what's figured
this out together I was going through a
difficult times Jason Kander served in
Afghanistan was elected secretary of
state of Missouri how y'all doing
almost won a US Senate seat and then ran
for mayor of Kansas City before abruptly
dropping out I was going through a
pretty difficult time suicidal thoughts
PTSD had been had really come to a head
for me but the mission of the veterans
community project changed that is the
project therapy for me
yeah the project relies on individual
contributions and corporate donors and
today candor is in charge of expanding
it nationwide
some guy living under a bridge comes in
here yep
comes in here and is now surrounded by
veterans who have a shared experience
with him can help reactivate that sense
of pride and accomplishment and that
shared sense of community maybe even
more it restores that sense of dignity
right that sense that says hey what you
served your country and we're gonna
treat you like you served your country
so far 2000 other communities across the
country have contacted the project to
see if they too could start a
neighborhood of tiny houses and big
hopes for CBS this morning Dean Reynolds
Kansas City